[Music]  the Bachelorette begins filming I think  any girl would probably love to do the  Bachelorette  well creator Mike Fleiss posted some  behind the scenes with a smiley Becca at  the mansion he showed off more suitors  shaming one and check out the guy in a  chicken suit in front of him is Ryan the  banjo player from Boston  meanwhile Becca's former fiance of about  six weeks Arie and his new fiance Lauren  escape to Spain  we're live they have yesterday the  couple checked into a two-story suite of  Barcelona's Iberostar Paseo de Gracia  the state is costly twenty five thousand  dollars but getting away from those most  hated bachelor billboards priceless  we're gonna take it one day at a time  we're just gonna do us